Crazy's deadlines you've ever had and
how did the boss in you make sure they
got well it wasn't the boss in me
because the boss was the producer in two
cases one of the cases was a USA Network
movie that had fought that fell apart
they on their schedule you know when
you're dealing with a cable company like
HBO or or Showtime or Cinemax or USA
Network or a lifetime or sci-fi channel
they have a big board that shows you
what movies are playing on there you
know for each the these days I guess
you'd probably know about TV movies from
sci-fi channel and short nado but there
so is like when the scheduled sharknado
2 they put it on the board for its gonna
show this night at this time and I had a
movie on you it wasn't my movie there
was a movie on USA Network that was on
their big board that fell apart and so I
got a call from a producer who said they
had a movie that fell out at the last
moment we need to make the movie for
them what are we gonna make and so I
wouldn't and pitched ideas to them and
they they had a location that was the
interesting thing is they had a location
called the orkut ranch in the valley
which is a gigantic orange orchard with
a hacienda on it and all kinds of cool
stuff it's a city you know city owns it
and they rent it out for basically
weddings and so i toured the property
went back pitched three or four ideas
they picked one and after they picked
the idea they said you have 12 days to
turn in your first draft and here's the
catch that first here's the first draft
is going out to talent so the actors
we're gonna try to get to take reduced
wages on this film now if they're not
what they get paid but less than that
are gonna be reading your 12 day first
draft and I said okay and I wrote the
script in ten days had two days left
they were to do a rewrite and those were
that's my suggestion for anyone working
in an insane deadline is always leave
two days to do a rewrite
no matter what the same deadline is
because those two days I made that
script a million times better than the
first draft and it went out they cast a
oscar-nominated actress and the female
lead
to work way below her rate and you know
that it ended up being cool the other
one what's even worse was a a Roger
Corman movie I did about robot hookers
from outer space
and I had 9 days to write it the film
was shot in 9 days and it played on
Showtime for nine days Corman had to
deal with Showtime at the time played on
Showtime for nine days so it was nine
days to write nine days to shoot the
nine days on Showtime then it was ABBA
there but it was that was interesting
because it was going to be done on a
really low budget Corman and it had to
be about rope I went in and it started
out I had a script it was very much like
Blade Runner a female lead Blade Runner
story about the world of robot rights
and a lawyer who's fighting for robot
rights who gives murdered and the
suspect one of the suspects is a male
robot escort and so the female detective
goes to interview the mail robot escort
who's known as a pleasure droid which by
the way I coined that phrase and in
Entertainment Weekly managed to say you
know pleasure droids you know which from
my movie and then they went through and
reviewed a whole bunch of other movies
with that had to do with sex robots but
pleasure droids on my tombstone I
invented that phrase but that after
pitching my story to to Korman's people
they said can it be about robot hookers
from outer space and I said does it have
to be outer space the hood yes and I
said does it have to be hookers and they
said yes and I said it doesn't have to
be robots and they said yes I said okay
I can do it they said nine days and so I
had basically nine days to write that
script and it turned out okay and is
what it is and it is a movie about robot
hookers from outer space with all of the
things you can imagine that might be I
did not it's not a serious film at all
and the problem was like Corman's people
thought it was so that the video
packaging is hysterical because they try
to turn a story about robot hookers from
outer space into a
his threat against our lives because
these robot hookers from outer space or
here now I'm like this is just silly
because it's a robot of hookers man it
can't be serious
my idea was to do the ultimate boob job
the whole robot hookers a boob and you
know they're there they walk into walls
in the script there's all kinds of funny
stuff and and some of the jokes got cut
out because they wanted a serious movie
about robot hookers from outer space
which neither the director nor I could
figure out what that movie might be and
but nine days I wrote it in nine days
director shot in nine days
you